salve siamo tornati con lo sfondo bianco
finalmente principalmente perché così
riuscite a vedere lo schifo che avete
sullo schermo che senza uno sfondo
bianco non vedrete mai
prego e oggi sono vestito per
presentarvi il nuovo iphone
e siccome siamo nel periodo a noi in
questa festa che tutti festeggiare
l'italia nessuno sa che cazzo voglia
dire parliamo di film horror
potrei partire da quando ero piccolo ma
probabilmente avrete due palle così
perché ve l'ho ripetuto fino
all'esaurimento
vi posso solo dire che guardare piccoli
brividi the hunting hours è chi ha paura
del buio aiutato alla mia crescita
cinematografica horror solo quel genere
però perché negli altri campi o pop
nebbia e prima di andar toccare i punti
veri di questo titolo lasciatemi citare
qualche maestro dell'horror perché
altrimenti mi fanno un bacio così se non
lo faccio sono cresciuto e non solo
perché poi ripresi da più grandicello
perché altrimenti non hanno non capito
un cazzo di quelli che stavano dicendo
gli attori di dario argento bava fulci
ma anche gente che magari di fi ne ha
fatti due è però son decenti
magari non proprio horror ma più
thriller horror come alex infascelli o
federico zampaglione incantate i
tiromancino e queste sono la parte
italiana perché poi dovrei andare nella
parte estera e sarei per due ore
elencarvi registi tedeschi tipo andreas
nas o film come da scoma brutale duel in
cui si cucivano i cervelli quale
pinzatrici ma questo è un altro discorso
francesi spagnoli e poi ovviamente gli
immancabili inglesi americani ma siccome
non sono un vero recensore
cinematografico buttiamo via tutta
questa roba e parliamo dell'argomento
principale gli horror ma quali ora come
ora sarebbe talmente banale facile fare
un video dove si parla male dei film
horror recenti che ante servono manco le
parrucche per fare una parodia per dire
però il fatto che sia banale è perché
tecnicamente è vero non nel 100 per
cento dei casi ci sono film recenti
horror usciti molto molto molto belli
come per esempio di consuming mamma ma
mi sto dilungando di nuovo ormai infatti
è diventato solo un ovvio
porta si è mossa horror perché
ricordiamolo che gli spiriti ce l'hanno
con i mobili se ci fate caso non ce
l'hanno mai con gli inquilini c'erano
sempre con i mobili della cucina e con
le credenze con le porte degli
sgabuzzino sono impiegati morti
dell'ikea prova il metodo e poi quel
genere quella parola che per anni ha
terrorizzato il web è che fortunatamente
sta scemando un po quei porca [ __ ] di
jobs kerr
avete presente no quei momenti in cui
uno sta parlando lentamente sta
camminando con la musica che man mano
sale e tu sai che sta per arrivare
qualcosa e poi forum vi siete pagati
pensavate che stesse per apparire tipo
la fascia dell'esorcista all'improvviso
con un urlo disumano che visse tra
forava i timpani e invece no non lo farò
perché poi me lo devo guardare il
montaggio e poi mica guai e non va bene
perché ormai non è più quello che vedi
che ti spaventa da quello che senti è
l'equivalente di quando vai a dormire a
casa dei tuoi amici e la mamma del tuo
amico simpatico la prende la padella e
ci dà dentro un cucchiaio bebè bebè per
svegliarti allo scherzo a ti ritrovi
sgozzato nella vasca da bagno
tutto questo mi aveva portato anni fa a
cercare per conto mio un altro tipo di
cinema horror che oserei definire per
antonomasia quello più pesante quello è
più scioccante è quello che ti porti
dietro come un masso sulle spalle film
che appunto visivamente ti mettevano
addosso raccapriccio e paura che guarda
caso è la definizione della maggior
parte di siti internet della parola
horror chi deve suscitare quelle
emozioni per tra l'altro il genere
horror essendo molto ampio nei suoi
contenuti perché ci sono mille mila
sottogeneri nel sapere neanche come
spiegare di quale esattamente faccio
prima a raccontarvi qualche scena ve lo
dico subito ci saranno mini micro
spoiler di questi film
e queste scene le racconterò esattamente
come sono quindi saranno un po esplicite
e questo è curioso perché io sono una
persona abbastanza sensibile sotto quel
punto di vista ma solo dal punto di
vista della vita vera effettivamente mi
sto accorgendo che vi sto spiegando le
cose senza che voci stiate capelli un
gas ma qui è affetta quello era un liceo
assistito a una cosa a cui non avevo mai
assistito non nella vita vera
un mio amico sto ma stavamo giocando a
calcetto cade con il portiere che tra
l'altro la fallo ma nessuno ha fischiato
e noi tutti a ridere indicavano quindi
merda si tira su il braccio gli era
diventato un pezzo del meccano ci
mancava solo la sfera di metallo dentro
del giro mag per metterlo a posto si era
fratturato l'ulna era di si era
scomposta la frattura è no non abbiamo
più liso dopo è stato per me scioccante
vedere quella cosa lì infatti io ho una
memoria di merda ma quella cosa lì non
me la sono mai dimenticata se mi
avessero scritto i libri di storia e
geografia sul braccio rotto del mio
compagno probabilmente non mi sarà in
più dimenticato niente ma questo è un
altro discorso
non solo l'immagine del suo braccio che
ho visto per una frazione di secondo
lui è ancora lì e lo dicevo di vago non
solo il braccio rotto la visione del
braccio rotto che ripete e stato un
attimo ma è stato la sua faccia quando
l'ha visto la sua faccia quando si è
reso conto che il braccio aveva qualcosa
che non andava ed il suo urlo sono stati
non mi sono rimaste dentro e c'è stato
un altro caso eclatante di un amico la
cui voto l'ha voluto proprio spostarsi
di 10 centimetri dal suo ginocchio che
per andare stata una scena molto bene lo
ringrazio tantissimo perché noi aveva i
pantaloni lunghi e tirando un calcio al
pallone e si è spostata alla rotula e
non poteva lasciare le urla le han han
o'toole ha voluto da ma senza input
visivo chissenefrega lui no alla rotula
aspetta che mi tiro sul pantalone della
faccia vedere porta a kailua e lì è
stato il momento in cui proprio quasi
stavo per svenire è lì ho capito che
queste cose qui non riesco a guardando
riesco a sopportarle nella vita vera
i film invece è tutta un'altra questione
tutto iniziato quando girando per i siti
di cinema anche quelli tipo forum
sconosciutissimi si parlava di questi
film non arrivati mai in italia o
arrivati solo in direct to video vhs
quando ancora pace all'anima loro
c'erano ancora alle biblioteche e si
parlava di questi film molto violenti
quasi al limite del trash ma da fermo
ma si sa non so passare quella linea
perché la linea tra un bel violento e
trash violento come fu per ricchi o e il
passo è breve ma si fermavano sempre
prima e uno dei primi film che ho visto
che non ha sorpassato la linea è stato
me le ba
se ti come sono british membrane sanno
racconta dei campi di prigionia asiatici
durante la seconda guerra mondiale in
cui venivano torturati i prigionieri e
siccome vele sto parlando di questo
video non venivano di certo torturati a
schiaffoni tipo fracchia belva umana
qualche esempio di tortura potrebbe
essere prendo una donna le riscaldare
congelano riscaldano e congelano
riscaldano i con generano molte volte le
braccia per vedere l'effetto che fa
vengo anch'io no tu no è tutto nei più
macroscopici dettagli giusto per la
cronaca quello che ti succede che la tua
pelle la tua carne a un certo punto si
staccano dall'osso come se fosse il
coperchio della pentola e quindi vedi le
immagini abbastanza forti per l'epoca
adesso forse un po vecchiotto il film di
questa donna con le braccia senza carne
senza pelle con le ossa che urla oppure
senza spoilerare troppo in questo
laboratorio c'era una stanza con dove si
poteva modificare la pressione
atmosferica buttano nuovo nudo io non
sono un astrofisico ma credo che tu
quella cosa l'hanno la possa fare ad un
uomo senza le conseguenze e le
conseguenze quali sono che questo
pover'uomo con la pressione sulle spalle
viene spiaccicato alterna e il suo
intestino esce fuori tipo stella filante
a carnevale
certo sono un film tutta finzione tua
mamma ti dice che il sangue solo succo
di pomodoro per oggi ali giardi c'era
qualcosa che non andava in queste scene
non avevo mai visto delle scene del
genere nei film horror è la cosa più
scioccante di tutto ciò è che io non ero
spaventato anzi ero lì che guardavo
affascinato queste scene incredibili
cena che non aveva quella scena proprio
che ti mette una croce sopra fi da dove
prendono riempiono una stanza piena
zeppa di topi veli e ci buttano dentro
un gatto zero per vedere l'effetto che
fa
inutile dire che i topi hanno fatto il
grande pranzo di natale e lo spettatore
intanto si stava cavando gli occhi con
le unghie io no però ripeto ero lì e
guardavo affascinato di quella scena lì
tra le fessure delle dica però non
potevo distoglierlo
e lo so che adesso arriveranno chi ama
gli animali a dirmi ha ucciso il gatto
hanno usato i topi e vero però hanno
anche tolto l'intestino ad alcuni di un
uomo
avete ragione è però ormai mi sa che in
un po inutile lamentarsene perché il
film degli anni ottanta mi sembra quindi
mi sa che sono tutti morti quelli che
hanno fatto il film mi spiace e dargli
poi è stata tutta una discesa o una
salita dipende dai punti di vista sono
andato a cercarmi tutti i film di quel
genere di che ripeto è molto difficile
capire qua in genere scioccante o come
preferisco chiamarlo io e in genere
destabilizzante e io ne ho visto in a
vagonate ma ogni volta che leggo un
titolo una trama che ha qualche
particolare un po intrigante lo guardo
subito anche se la maggior parte sono
film di merda perché politiche siano
belli se ci sono queste cerqui
semplicemente vuol dire che gli
interessano altri esempi che mi vengono
in mente più conosciuti per esempio cani
parolo caos il monumentale di ruggero
deodato in cui ci sono uccisi emiliani
margherita le scene più agghiaccianti
possiamo ricordare quella dove i
protagonisti trovano un enorme
testuggini un enorme tartaruga di mare
quelle belle grossi vera e l'agire una
pancia in su viva e come un enorme
coltello da caccia che neanche ambo
iniziano a car varla come se fosse un
gioco survival staccano quella membrana
dura possiamo dire la pancia della
tartaruga per vedere da viva cosa
succede al suo interno ed è disgustoso
ci sono gli organi che ancora in vita
pulsano di sangue tutto gelatinoso e io
sempre lì a guardare non possono non
posso proprio moralmente io invece mi
sento attratto da queste cose qua è tra
i meno conosciuti o nel senso forse
conosciuti solo da una piccola parte di
gente cioè quelli che l'hanno visto
perché magari i fermi conoscono tutti ma
poi nessuno se li volerle tutelano clima
così come a serbian film film nel film
in cui il regista fa vedere una scena
l'attore in questa scena si vede un
finto dottore che fa partorire una donna
si vede tutto a partorire una donna
prende il feto appena nato e inizia a
fare cose perché fortunatamente
l'inquadratura era dalle spalle però
alla mente viaggia per non parlare di
di masturbazione in presenza di minori
eccetera eccetera oppure uno dei miei
preferiti che human senti p2 perché poi
non avete idea di quanta gente mi chieda
di recensire 1 st soltanto perché c'è un
100 piedi umano e quindi c'è un 100
piedi umano e quindi cosa così e brutto
il film o lo devo recensire solo perché
c'è uno che fa un 100 piedi umano yes e
appunto nessuno mi sa dare una
giustificazione vera del perché dovrei
recensire un film che devo dirle un bel
film sia tecnicamente che attorialmente
però non erano recensisco perché c'è
qualche cosa di dire che dovessere
cesine l'esorcista perché c'è un
esorcista dei tre voti per chi non
sapesse la trama parla di questo dottore
pazzo che prende due ragazze e un
ragazzo e chirurgicamente le unisce
insieme unendo la bocca di uno all'anno
dell'altro per fare un 100 piedi umano
per altro film e accurato cento per
cento chirurgicamente
non so perché ne dubito ma uno è la
trama è quella però il film tu lo fai
vedere per quello non è che lo vai a
vedere perché chissà quale colpo di
schiena incredibile alla fine ma i due
probabilmente dieci volte peggio che
vabbè avendovi appena raccontato la
tappa di quello di prima potete
immaginare la premessa di lui è questa
il primo nell'universo del film del
secondo film il primo film è un film
anche nel secondo film e c'è questa
guardia di sicurezza di un parcheggio
multipiano che se lo guarda
ma est asiatico come tutti guardiamo i
film che ci piacciono c'è lui prende due
pezzi di carta vetrata si tira giù i
pantaloni inizia a masturbarsi con la
carta vetrata guardando il film no
prodotti intanto nel tempo libero per
noi sviluppa un amore morboso verso
questa pellicola accetta di la madre lo
fa parlare con uno psicologo ma non
funziona niente e lui inizia a menare la
gente nel parcheggio di notte per creare
un 100 piedi umano di 12 persone stanno
tranquilli non ce la fa a farlo di 12
persona lo fa solo di nove meno male e
meno male perché sono poteva risultare
volgare ea sul giro non c'è niente di
100 per cento accurato chirurgicamente
anzi c'è quest'uomo che fa tutto con una
pinzatrice con un martello con un
martello
lo sly alle persone in una scena che ha
dell'incredibile perché tutta fatta
presadiretta sfondare i denti dei
malcapitati per per togliere perché
ovviamente non è che puoi attaccare
l'anno di uno coi denti dell'altro è
ovvio sfonda i denti con un martello e
prendi i lembi della pelle del sedere
degli altri appiccica con una pinzatrice
esco il mio chirurgo è che gli dobbiamo
dire non ci fa così e ci mancherebbe
e siccome questo turbine di violenza sia
fisica che psicologica non basta dei cd
riprende una bella siringo là di quelle
quasi comiche piene di lassativo e la
netta nel sedere di tutte e nove le
persone perché voleva somma divertirsi
sarò quella cosa mai risaputa che c'è un
po di imbarazzo tra te i tuoi genitori
quando durante un film c'è una scena di
sesso
immagina di l'imbarazzo di due i suoi
genitori quando vedi nove persone che si
cagano in bocca è bello ea natale noi
abbiamo e poi potrei citarvi nei tanti
altri un po underground tipo la serie di
chi ne ha p consiglio riprende il
secondo chi ne ha picker perché per
l'epoca quegli effetti li artigianali
non sono probabilmente imbattuti forse
solo carpenter
tutto questo per giungere a quale
conclusione del sapere perché mi
piacciono queste cose perché è vero che
i gusti son gusti
ti piace non ti piace sono cavoli tuoi
l'ho sentito dentro è come quando si è
innamorato solo tu lo puoi sapere però
questo caso un po particolare vorrei
vorrei proprio capire perché mi piaccia
a guardare quelle cose lì oltre a tutto
il resto è la cosa curiosa è che io
nella vita nera probabilmente mi
butterei giù da un balcone se vedessi
una psicosi generale di questo dubbio
che mi attanaglia perché poi si potrebbe
parlare di effetto deragliamento cioè
quell istinto animale che ti sale quando
senti un incidente stradale e devi
correre ad andarlo a vedere anche se i
fa schifo che ti tagli con la carta con
il foglio tra le dita muori
ma devi andare a vedere la gente
sfracellata nell'incidente stradale per
poi magari guardare mezzo a situazioni
sicuro però ci proprio quell'istinto che
ti fa diventare un uomo primitivo dove
devi quasi scoprire qualcosa che non hai
mai
visto il motivo per cui io non mi sono
mai più dimenticato braccio rotto e la
rotta una scappata di casa e perché non
ho mai visto tu la tua mente non ha mai
visto una cosa del genere
mettevi film guardando lo sai che è
finta nella vita vera e destabilizzante
proprio perché tu sei stabile nella tua
mentalità normale e c'è qualcosa che
l'apt e stabilizza la rotula spostata al
braccio rotto la macchina ribaltata con
il sangue
magari qualcuno si taglia il
sopracciglio ne è completamente sporco
di sangue tu lo devi guardare a tutti i
costi e potrei sbagliarmi ma è proprio
quella curiosità del guardare qualcosa
che non hai mai visto anche se potrebbe
avere ripercussioni negative sulla tua
mente non vorrei fare un esempio troppo
esagerato ma è un po come lo scoprire lo
spazio profondo è una curiosità immensa
ma anche una grande grande paura perché
non ha idea di come potresti reagire
scoprendo determinate cose e purtroppo
non ho ancora una risposta ma è una di
quelle domande che in realtà c'è ti
piacciono fine poi film vero io mi
diverto a capire il perché quando io
racconto una di queste cose
ricevi ogni ogni volta la risposta è
sempre la stessa speriamo che vengano ad
arrestare perché non se ne può più di
sarah ascoltare però sto mangiando
almeno non a cena magari la risposta sta
proprio nel contrasto
il fatto che io non riesca a vedere
determinate cose nella mia vita e il
probabile che sia una specie di terapia
d'urto e una compensazione mentale
quella di guardarla in pellicola perché
appunto è solo salsa di pomodoro e non è
di certo una voglia di volar ii e
neanche di essere al posto loro non è
che domani mi metto a stuprare feti ma è
che però forse sta un po uscendo dal mio
campo perché io sono solo uno che fa
video su youtube comici non sono posso
parlare di psicologia e di astrofisica
buon halloween
[Musica]